the city of Santa Clarita California
just north of Los Angeles continues to
grieve this morning following this
week's deadly shooting at Saugus high
school the alleged shooter 16 year old
junior Nathaniel burr how died Friday
while being treated for a self-inflicted
gunshot wound to his head the two teens
he was accused of murdering have now
been identified 15 year old Gracie mule
burger and 14 year old Dominic blackwell
as Carter Evans reports they leave
behind a community struggling to make
sense of this tragedy this was the scene
Thursday morning in Saugus high school
when a student opened fire on his 16th
birthday he shot five classmates killing
two we did not find any manifesto any
diary that spelled it out any suicide
note or any writings which will clearly
identify his motive behind this assault
Nia Paige treta is recovering from a
gunshot wound
authorities say all of the victims were
chosen at random but the attack was
deliberate it wasn't a
spur-of-the-moment act they say when
16-year old Nathaniel Burke out took out
his 45 caliber handgun it initially
jammed in 16 seconds he cleared a
malfunction and was able to shoot five
people in himself so he seemed very
familiar with firing the weapon an
entire community is now trying to heal
as they face a disturbing reality here
was a 16 year old with a girlfriend a
member of his school's cross-country
team now the country's latest mass
shooter
she was cooperative and interview and
she's as shocked as everyone else Yvette
Oheka was in Burr House English class I
was in shock I was like that cannot be
him he didn't fit the profile of what
you hear of as a typical school shooter
yeah and that scares me even more
because you realize how easy it is for
it to happen again investigators say
they found several guns inside the
shooters home some were registered to
his late father others were not
registered at all the ATF is still
trying to determine where he got the 45
caliber handgun you
to the attack for CBS this morning
Saturday Carter Evans Santa Clarita
California